tan
ana
An unknown energy that sleeps in this planet
Seireimu dwells inside Witches and genies pass through white plums
Big
Two countries have read a
lot, so it's a long
battle  I want it to end There's
such a happy me
Why are we at our peak?
07 butter
ana for the first time in a year ana
I want a full-scale war against us regular users and the empire along the Irem village in the
empire
.
Who taught Chiba Kumagai how
to do it before
I can't
win?  Two bills are
rushing away He's always near the lady's tea
Strong luck that can't lose to any succubus The maid is tied
After buying you who should be the next queen Cut
off the sound of the c  Let me cut the
main gate to my heart
, but I only
know what you think.
Transcendence
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
I can't meet you much even in the 100 deadly sins magazine
There is no doubt that it is the target of the squirrel
[Music]
100 years ago, the
great Shiso-sama's mansion was turned into a sea of ​​fire.
It's a thought and position that
I can't enter It's not the performance that's why I fight Then
what do you think of me The
future that Otsuki aims for
is not there The
world that aims for me is not there There is
no future where you can stop me
Know the anger of your waist
You are no longer the hero of a certain chain I
don't need you in this era
[music]
Create an ugly world And hey
[music] The
holy war that will change our world has begun